the kentucky derby the run for the roses
is this weekend it's also the second
annual day at the derby for a local las
vegas organization helping hands of
vegas valley i spoke with nina gallagher
development director for the non-profit
about how you can join in on the fun
it's the second annual day at the derby
and it's such a fun event i had the
honor of hosting last year and i get to
do it again this year nina thank you so
much
how did the idea for day at the derby
come about it was really a group of us
sitting around in the office talking
about new ideas to to bring more
awareness about our mission at helping
hands of vegas valley and so it started
with the tea party and ended up talking
about derby and fancy hats and whatnot
and you sure do play the part well and
uh yeah we we've got video showing the
event from uh last year and it is really
all about hats this year of course 2022
is the second annual and and i it sounds
like it's just going to be an ongoing
tradition and this year at the las vegas
country club yes beautiful venue hoping
for great weather of course
but so much to do there silent auction
raffle what else yes
we'll have a performer who's going to
sing beautiful songs with a genre from
jazz that's great a jazz singer
plus you have a
wine poll where you get to
do blind pools for great wines and dine
and dash
it's a it's a huge wall with over 50
gift cards ranging from increments of
twenty dollars to a hundred dollars so
you pay your twenty dollar fee and have
the opportunity to possibly win that
hundred dollar gift card oh my goodness
it was just so fun last year there was a
fashion show yes
yes and this year we opted for a singer
okay and she's amazing she's a local
singer-songwriter and it'll be a great
evening fantastic talk about helping
hands of vegas valley what is the
mission of the non-profit so helping
hands in vegas valley our mission is to
create an impact in the lives of our
senior citizens and their families
through a number of programs that we
offer for free to a senior citizen and
that's everything from pantry to
transportation to respite care and even
home repair oh my goodness and um i've
volunteered and i've done some of those
grocery deliveries especially during the
pandemic yes some of these people are in
a bad way and they they need help how
was life during the pandemic for
non-profits like yours for ours really
we had to make a pivot in regards to how
we performed our services and how we
gave because it brought
a huge light upon the real need in the
valley and so our seniors
came out in full force in regards to the
need because
organizations like yourselves like news
8 brought some awareness to what we do
and and how we do it and so
we became really creative because of the
pandemic there were several different
rules and how we approached our seniors
and so we put safety measures in place
in order for us to continue to feed them
to provide assistance in housing
respite care and like i said
transportation
but really it more than doubled our
clientele because of the pandemic and so
we heavily rely upon our community
partners to come together to bring a
collaborative effort to make that larger
impact and this is a big fundraiser for
you if people are interested and would
still like to come and get tickets where
do they go please visit our website
hhov.org
you'll find it on our day at the derby
and our tickets right now are going for
a hundred dollars we hope to see
everyone yeah lots of food fun drinks
and good entertainment and yes helping
seniors in our valley who need it so
much the need is still there right it
exists and we've been doing this for the
last 22 years well great organization
great to see you nina thank you
fantastic in your hatred we should see
you on saturday